whoa whoa
is somebody walking in here
[Music]
get out of here what is going on where
are we Zach explain to the world where
we are right now they already know just
look well if you live in LA you already
know what this house is this
is one of the scariest locations that we
have ever invested say the name of the
place Los Felice murder mansion
heard of it yeah it's one of the most
mysterious places on the planet that we
have ever investigated Kevin you've
covered a few different segments with me
before at the haunted Museum I'm going
to tell you something right now and I
wish that I this was
but I feel my back tightening up are you
serious I'm not kidding you right now
then you gotta there's no way and I'm
not I'm not kidding you right now
you are
I'm not I'm gonna walk over here I'm
just gonna walk over here it's because
you mocked it that's not because I might
this is like this is some real full-on
spooky craziness I don't understand
really that's the weirdest thing that's
ever happened you've had some things
affect you you've had to leave an
interview once because of being affected
you have a sensitivity and what do you
carry around in your backpack still to
this day three years later in my luggage
you gave me Sage after I felt a back
injury after sitting on that haunted
rocking chair and because of that I keep
it to this day I carry Sage with me that
Zach gave me and the one day you need it
the most you forgot to bring it I'm
freaked out right now okay so what
happened in this house for people who
don't know okay so the Los Felice murder
Mansion this is in Los Felice now Los
Felice in general is known to have a
curse because back in 1838 Domingo
Felice he owned Rancho Los Feliz
he was killed by his wife's lover and
then his wife and that lover were
executed then a descendant of his named
Don Felice ended up dying and he was
going to give all of his money to his
niece petronilla but a lawyer and
another guy were able to Swindle that
money and change his will on his
deathbed petronila cursed this land it
is very well known and when petronilla
cursed this land she cursed all of
Griffith Park and the Greek Theater
first yes yes yes yes but that curse has
permeated throughout this entire soil
throughout this throughout this entire
land so the Los Feliz murder Mansion a
very mysterious a very scary place if
you're lived in Los Angeles you have
walked up here you've tried to sneak in
you know about the ghost stories but in
1959 a guy named Dr Harold Pearson who
was a cardiologist he wakes up all of a
sudden on December 6th in the early
morning gets up grabs a ball peen hammer
goes to his wife that's sleeping in bed
attacks her
skull and kills her after that he takes
that hammer he tries to go kill his
oldest daughter she ended up Surviving
and fled out the back after that he
killed himself now nobody knows exactly
why he did this a lot of people say it's
from financial reasons but the really
weird part about this is there was a
open book next to his body of Dante's
Divine Comedy and that deals with like
Dante's Inferno the The Nine Circles of
hell so why did he have this book next
to his body that's dealing with the
afterlife
Satan purgatory and all that kind of
stuff the big question is was Dr
perilson being affected by something
dark in the house
so now from what I understand
the house remained the same it was sold
but remained the same nobody came in and
did anything no after Dr pearlson died
and did this murder-suicide there was a
family called the Enriquez family they
bought the house in 1960 but they never
moved in
they actually bought the house with all
of Dr perilson's belongings still in the
house there was wrapping paper there's
always different mysterious kinds of
artifacts and and things so if you look
at old pictures you can actually see
pictures of wrapping paper and all of
his belongings but he never moved in and
nobody has ever moved in this house has
gone on for decades
nobody can live in this house and we
talk to the neighbors over there if you
look at that house right there yeah we
spoke with those neighbors and they said
that recently one of the owners he was
like a vampire they would only ever see
him at night he would never live in the
house but he only did things in here at
night the people that worked on that
what do you think was going on in here I
think there's something dark there
because in Los Feliz there is a known
curse all of Los Feliz Kevin has been
stigmatized with these types of events
and the LA Bianca murders happen
right over there all of Los Felice I
believe there is something dark in this
house what is what is in that house
you're gonna go in and you're gonna find
out with us but listen what is in the
house Zach
you I don't know but that's why you're
here you listen I told you that I was
gonna bring you on a Ghost Adventures
investigation yes you happen to choose
everybody watching this Kevin Frazier
right here
he wanted to come to one of the most
scariest locations that we have ever
investigated so listen this is a very
serious thing that's going on here a lot
of things have happened to our crew
since then we've captured a lot of
evidence we captured a crazy voice a
couple different crazy voices a piece of
wood went flying I want a what a piece
of wood here's what I want to ask you I
don't see a lot of lights around here
does the is there electricity in there
no it's Pitch Black
so what are we going to do well we don't
we we work in the pitch black
the creatures of the night like to work
in the uh pitch black so we don't want
to what do we hope what do we hope to
find what do we hope to find here we
hope to find an answer to Kevin listen
this
this is a very serious investigation
because yeah we are the only crew
ever
to ever be allowed to investigate the
Los Felice murder house after this he's
going to continue trying to renovate it
because the owner is here the new owner
is here right new owners here but we've
been trying to get in here for many many
years the new owner told us that even
his contractor refused to ever come back
here from things that he experienced and
a lot of the other workers why are you
looking so nervous I'm I'm tripping why
I'm tripping you want me to go into
murder house yes but our there's no
common sense it says go in the murder
house via
the up two hour investigation is very
serious we must not forget
Lillian died here in her sleep by the
man that she loved
there is no reason why this guy would
have just tripped and what do we need to
say financially what do we need to know
Lillian can't come back something else
dark here that consumed his body okay so
it can consume us yes
we met the owner and he's going to come
in and he's going to make all these
changes to the house and apparently he's
not concerned about it should he be
concerned
yes absolutely he should be very
concerned because his own contractor has
refused to step in so how's his work
going to continue who buys this house
why does he buy this house actor will
not go back in the house because of
things happening this house has been
talked about for decades it is one of
the most notoriously haunted murder
houses in all of Southern California and
I like that you're here I like that you
are a third party somebody that I
believe has a sensitivity from things
that I've seen you witness before but I
think it's very important for you to
document this as well and to witness our
investigation is there any chance we can
go in while it's still light no
we're gonna wait until it gets dark
you know I mean I think you feel the
same thing whether it's light or dark no
and what's the difference because things
what's the difference things change what
changes Zach it's still the same house
the vibe Zach your crew said they were
freaked out from being in there they are
they're very freaked out and then I have
a scratch right here on my grinal area
from what from being in here I woke up
the next morning and I have a huge the
ghosts are scratching you what are we
doing y'all
what equipment are you giving us what do
I have to protect myself
um yourself and whatever spiritual
guides that you have do I get across or
do I get a like do I get something do
you bring some Sage I will be honest
with you I brought a bottle of holy
water I don't bring it often but I did
forget it
but I was like give me the holy water
now I'm sprinkling it all over I'm gonna
take a bath in holy water right now this
is crazy I thought I had it but listen
Experian experiencing this stuff is is
cool is is is fascinating is intriguing
we don't get opportunities like this a
lot to investigate a house like this I
also heard that Lisa Bloom
bought this house for a minute Gloria
allred's daughter Lisa Bloom the lawyer
bought the house and then she never
moved in she bought it for a second and
she's the one who started the gutting
I don't want to be on this hill right
now I think I'm moving in the house I
don't want to be standing here in front
of the house where somebody died I was
on a haunted hill the original House on
Haunted Hill is directly behind this
house so like isn't that a double
entender let's go over the details
the caretakers will leave at midnight
locking Us in here until they come back
in the morning
once the door is locked there's no way
out
the windows have bars that a jail would
be proud of isn't that crazy right
behind her literally is the House on
Haunted Hill yeah right behind here
right up behind it it's very ironic
there's there's nothing going on here we
are standing on Haunted Hill but you
have the House on Haunted Hill up there
that was used in the movie they filmed
like Blade Runner and things like that
but then like literally directly beneath
it you have the actual House on Haunted
Hill I mean this is it we're going in
the house we have to wait till dark
all right we're gonna wait till dark
guys and then we're gonna go in the
house
are you no I'm not okay I'm not okay I'm
gonna go in I'm gonna go in with you I'm
going in with you I want it but listen
and this is not for any dramatic effect
or anything like that but listen as part
of the Ghost Adventures initiation we do
this with everybody that wants to join
us on an investigation we're selective
of that
but we will leave you alone somewhere in
the house
for you to absorb the energy and for us
to watch you from outside in nerve
center set up in a van are you okay with
that
yeah that's
are you we're gonna try Zach we're gonna
try it so I have to be by myself like
completely by myself yes in the murder
house yes this is our window of
opportunity an investigation will never
happen again so to be able to analyze
somebody that isn't a part of our crew
right to see what would happen to you is
a very valuable experiment for our
investigations we need to know more
about what's going on in this house
because it started in 1920s so they want
me to go in a house where there was a
murder suicide that hasn't been opened
for decades no one's ever lived in sit
in there by myself in the dark
hoping that I connect with the murderous
haunted spirits
[Music]
the name of science yes that's that's
like all right well Zach let's let's do
it let's do it I can't I'll be honest
with you I was going to come up here
real Cavalier and brave and I was Brave
until I pulled up this road and then
everything changed you you feel it once
you turn this little corner and you
you're on this street you look up the
hill
this is menacing it's intimidating and
you don't even have to be inside by
looking at the windows especially look
at me look at this staircase on the
other side of this window
this house speaks it's trying to speak
so what you're going to be part of is a
lockdown style investigation and when I
say that we want to send you in alone we
want you to feel the energy of the house
and we want to observe you as part of an
experiment this is also the initiation
into our GAC Ghost Adventures crew
lockdown means that you are sealed
inside we will literally what do you
mean lock the back door shut so you
can't oh wait a minute nobody told me
what if I got to get out what if I got
to get out well yeah we have a key
somewhere we'll get it we'll get we'll
lock you out we're not going to keep you
in their hostage
I'll be honest with you I thought like
there'd be a camera guy and a sound guy
in there with me I'd be sitting with a
bunch of people and we'd be like ooh
scary I didn't know I was gonna get
locked in there by myself
that's ridiculous I'm laughing so I'm
not crying that's all I'm saying if the
same force that affected Dr Harold
Harrelson that we believe and others
we have new energy
to see if you have some type of reaction
or response to the energy in here that
we already know is in there from The
Voice okay but here's what I'm also
concerned about what is that there's
like rats and mice and stuff in there
yeah there's holes in the floor that's
what I'm saying I'm concerned I'll give
you a little light I'm concerned about
the rats and the mice because they feel
they're totally comfortable when the
lights are out in the dark they feel
great let me tell you something the rats
and the mice that's not what you have to
worry about in this house
what you have to worry about in this
house is what spoke to us last night did
you understand that
it wasn't like ubereats or something
like that it wasn't like no it wasn't
like your phone ringing no it was a
voice that manifested itself okay okay
all right let's go and we're gonna let a
minute now
I know do I get a do I get a safe word a
safe phrase like I'm locked in there and
I'm like oh oh the ghost has me we're
gonna be watching you listen I'm not
this is not this is let
this is level 10. okay this is level 10
location on the ghost adventure scale I
thought it would be better to start you
out maybe at a haunted toy shop or
something you know right into this why
not you got thrown in with a level 10.
you're right let's just let's scrap
today and I'll go down and I'll go to
the like the haunted restaurant for your
solo experiment for your solo assignment
that we would like you to do how about I
give you a walkie-talkie listen and all
realness we're gonna be watching you
right okay if something goes wrong
and I'm being serious you know I'm being
serious oh something going I mean if
something goes wrong I'm coming out
whether it's through a window or whether
it's something I'm coming out if
something happens we will immediately
come into to help you but we're only
going to do this for a small amount of
time to happen all right we're going to
go in and we are going to do a lockdown
style investigation where the complete
house is sealed we are going to padlock
the back door
um and we will join listen who green lit
this who says this is okay
um we are going to come in with
different types of of equipment and I
would like you to observe how we use
this equipment and I also want to suit
you up and have you use a particular
okay of equipment to use it so I'll know
if something's in the room with me
I got to be honest with you I'm
terrified to go up these stairs
it is like there's something on these
stairs that is pushing like I stepped up
for those stairs and I felt like there
was a weight on my back
it's very compelling that Kevin is
saying this because I experienced the
same exact thing and the exact same spot
last night
[Music]